as a customer what do you want out of a
smartphone affordability reliability
strong performance customizability well
one could argue that the Google pixel is
exactly that Google prices their pixel
phones very competitively for the
Western Market starting at just
$350 while offering nearly Flagship
level performance pixels also get strong
reviews both from users and DET Tech
journalists and pixels aren't some sort
of sketchy knockoff that you buy from
Alibaba either pixels come from one of
the largest and most reputable companies
in the world Google I mean even if you
don't especially like Google it might
make sense to get a pixel and enjoy a
strong smartphone experience on Google's
dime as such you would think that this
is the type of product that would
explode in popularity Google is solving
all of the issues that people generally
complain about when it comes to
smartphones and giving customers exactly
what they're asking for and to be fair
the pixel is performing quite well
within a niche portion of the population
but it's very much just a niche portion
of the population globally speaking
Google doesn't even control 1% of the
market despite having basically infinite
resources being around since the
beginning of smartphones and controlling
Android that's often pointed to as one
of Apple's largest advantages they're
able to control both the software and
Hardware to create the best experience
possible but can't Google do the exact
same thing with the pixel I'm picking on
Google here but I'm not talking about
Google really at all they're just the
most notable example you probably know a
bunch of other smartphone models that
are even more value packed maybe it's
from xiaomi or Samsung or Huawei or even
the iPhone se but regardless of which
value pack smartphone you're talking
about they all suffer from the same
problem no one buys them so here's why
the Google pixel is having such a tough
time becoming a big player and why you
should think twice before giving
customers exactly what they
want taking a look back Google's fora
with smartphones date all the way back
to the beginning of smartphones in 2009
this year Google would launch their
first ever smartphone the Android Dev
phone 1 for $400 they didn't Market this
phone very much because as the name
suggested it wasn't made for consumers
it was made for developers it didn't
take much longer for Google to launch a
consumer oriented phone though in 2010
they would come out with the Nexus 1 but
this itself would turn out to be a
massive flop why you ask well largely
because Google was going against the
grain instead of locking in contracts
with all of the big National Carriers
Google decided to sell the Nexus one
directly to Consumers for
$530 today this is pretty much standard
practice everyone knows about retail
pricing and contract pricing for
smartphones but back in the late 20 000s
and early 2010s there was only one
pricing model that the average person
was familiar with the contract pricing
model and this was the only way to buy
iPhones at least within the US you would
usually pay $100 or $200 up front for
the phone and sign a 2-year contract
with AT&T ryzon or Sprint from there you
would pay a set amount every month for 2
years until you paid off the full cost
of the smartphone the reason Apple did
this was to mask the true price of
iPhones and to make the price a lot more
digestible for a market that was seeing
smartphones for the first time it wasn't
until mid 2011 that Apple started
selling unlocked iPhones for retail
price on their website and it really
wasn't until the late 2010s and until
T-Mobile popularized unlock smartphones
that the average person became aware of
the difference between contract pricing
and Retail pricing until then as far as
the average person knew the price of an
iPhone was $200 that's what they would
have to pay up front and that's what
they saw everywhere at stores on TVs on
magazines on ads everywhere so when
Google came in with an unlocked phone in
2009 for
$530 the general public was naturally
put off by the seemingly high price
Google's position within the overall
Market has changed over the years but
there's still very much going against
the grain while everyone is selling
phones for $800 or $1,000 Google is
trying to sell phones for 500 to 600
bucks but it's the same underlying issue
by giving customers exactly what they
want you're always going to be going
against the industry at large which
naturally earns you a lot of skepticism
and the thing is the hardest people to
sell to are not the people who don't
want your product but the people who
don't trust your product if you try to
convince these people based on facts
they'll only be put off more they'll
start wondering if your product is truly
this awesome what's in it for you
basically what's the catch and that's
exactly what's happening with the Google
pixel over the years Google has built up
a reputation as someone who does shady
stuff to make money like collecting data
and intruding privacy so when Google
comes out with a smartphone that seems
too good to be true people immediately
wonder why and they're not wrong for
wondering why I mean it's not like
Google is handing out pixels at zero
margin as a philanthropic effort no
they're handing them out at zero margin
because they're okay with sacrificing
profit to gain market share and they
know that they can monetize your use of
the pixel using Google services so they
do indeed have ulterior motives and the
problem is that when you go against the
grain and give customers exactly what
they want these ulterior motives become
more visible than ever so Google is
constantly having to fight this uphill
battle against consumer skepticism but
that only tells half the story because
even consumers who aren't skeptical
don't want the
pixel from the very beginning the
smartphone industry has been somewhat of
an aspirational category half of this is
because of marketing and how smartphones
have been positioned over the years
Apple for example has simply leaned more
and more into premium branding
especially with the pro series
realistically speaking Apple knows that
the average person won't spring for the
Pro Series that's why 80% of the lineup
is not the pro series with that being
said though the pro series is actually
extremely important for the rest of
Apple's lineup because it provides
context it establishes apple as someone
who puts out top tier Pro level phones
and while you may not be able to
purchase the Pro Series today it gives
you something to Aspire to this is a
very common marketing technique used
across a wide range of Industries it's
the same reason why Costco puts a bunch
of super expensive TVs right at the
entrance it asserts that that's what the
most successful Costco Shoppers are
buying and by having a Costco membership
you too are part of that Elite group of
Shoppers it's the same thing with the
American Express black card as well most
of these items are something that the
average person will realistically never
get but the presence of these items are
what make all the difference so that's
the marketing side of things the other
half of the story is simply how
smartphones fit into our lifestyles the
average person spends over 3 hours on
their smartphones every day and if
you're on the younger side of things
that number is likely even higher as
such people don't view buying
smartphones the same way as buying trash
bags or paper towels or some other
household item with these sort of items
most people do just get the cheapest
option with the decent reliability with
smartphones however people see it as
more of an investment they're going to
end up spending thousands of hours on
this device so they're much more willing
to spend the extra $100 or $200 and get
the better phone even if they don't need
it and this only makes it even harder
for Google to sell the pixel even if
they're able to overcome these
skepticisms suring the pixel consumers
still just just don't want it it's more
than likely that the average consumer
would say something along the lines of
it's great that Google is offering a
well-priced competitive option but for
myself I'd like getting something a bit
more high-end and when they say high-end
they usually just mean getting a
lower-end iPhone for the same price
hearing this you might be saying that
Google just needs to advertise more if
they just put the pixel in front of
people more often people will finally
get it right well the truth is that
Google has already been spending
hundreds of Millions on marketing now to
be fair that is four to five times less
than Apple and Samsung historically but
here's the deal Google's market share is
not four to five times less than Apple
and Samsung it's more like 30 to 40
times less AKA despite being the king of
digital ads Google's return on
Advertising spend is garbage in
comparison to Apple and Samsung now this
could partially be due to the marketing
campaigns themselves Maybe Google's
campaigns just aren't as good but I
suspect that this has more to do with
all of the intangible factors that we've
been discussing apple and Samsung's
flagship phones simply strike a cord
with consumers that Google's budget
phones don't and this is largely because
smartphones are often an aspirational
guilty pleasure type of purchase not
something that's strictly objective or
logical and that brings us into the real
takeaway of all of this which is that
consumers often simp simply don't know
what they
want we often hear the business Mantra
that the customer is always right and in
some Industries like hospitality and
tourism that's a great slogan to live by
even if the customer is technically
wrong it's better to assume that they're
right to keep them happy this Mantra
however doesn't work all that well
within Tech or really any Innovation
driven industry because the truth is
customers have no clue what they really
want Henry Ford had this famous quote
that if he had asked customers for what
they wanted they would have said Faster
Horses Steve Jobs very much took this
quote to heart as he strongly believed
that people don't know what they want
until you show it to them that's why he
never relied on Market Research his task
was to read things that are not yet on
the page and this sort of Trailblazer
mindset is what led to many of Apple's
best Innovations for example choosing to
not use a stylus using intuitive methods
to zoom in and out by pinching the
screen instead of pressing a plus or
minus button face ID instead of touch ID
and so on often times Apple's products
aren't initially well received by the
public because consumers aren't
convinced that that's what they want the
iPhone x for example was memed as the
$1,000 Emoji machine and the airpods was
cofed at as overpriced Bluetooth
headphones but over time both of these
have become extremely popular in fact
the entire world is moving towards IOS
and Android is bleeding marketer and
this is especially true in developing
countries like India as soon as people
are able to afford an iPhone they tend
to get an iPhone and I'm not saying this
to Hype up Apple or something rather I'm
trying to illustrate how people don't
exactly do what they say if you ask
anyone they'll say what they want is a
reasonably priced reliable
smartphone but where they actually end
up spending their money is an overpriced
phone that fulfills intangible Valu such
as status aspirations fitting in and
whatever
else and the problem for Google is that
the pixel is a manifestation of what
people say they want not what they
really want with the historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times they still expect
people to use clunky Bond tables scroll
through long overwhelming lists and even
use virtual keyboards till recently and
that's why we created our own modern
Bond platform Silo at Silo we prioritize
the user experience and the ease of
finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust so that you too can
easily lock in high yields also choosing
a strong user experience does not mean
sacrificing on safety every Salo account
is insured by $500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC insurance
also all funds deposited on the platform
will be maintained by our trusted
custodian interactive brokers who has
experienced managing $373 billion worth
of assets over the past 45 years so if
you're looking for a modern way to
invest in bonds please consider checking
out Silo in the description below it
seems that this is the case not just for
the pixel but Android in general check
out this video to learn more but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next
one
am